bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors les bénéfices
d' amazon facebook et apple sont
aujourd'hui estimés à plus de 30
milliards d'euros au troisième trimestre
selon le financial times on imagine que
c'est le bon timing pour la france de
rouvrir ce dossier
non c'est clair c'est le moment où
effectivement et le ministre alors c'est
surprenant d'entendre dans la bouche
d'un ministre quand même de parler des
adversaires on part quand même sur un
autre terrain mais il faut avoir
conscience aujourd'hui que les grands
genres du numérique les surpassent les
états il ya plus de deux milliards sept
de personnes chez facebook
et effectivement le search de google qui
est devenu un service public et on
n'arrive pas taxées on n'arrive pas à
les prendre c'est comme s'ils étaient au
dessus des états donc oui le le
gouvernement et bruno le maire prend ce
moment là pour le faire dans un contexte
si où l'europe a pris a pris position à
1 tiret breton lui même a décidé de
légiférer donc clairement au wac et une
reprise en main parce que les enjeux
économiques sont terribles mais même les
enjeux sociaux aujourd'hui l'état ne
sait pas comment par exemple gérer la
parole gérer ce qui circule sur les
réseaux sociaux
ça me dépasse donc benoit lemay a
effectivement prendre action là dessus
là justement vous vous évoquez ce mot
d'adversaires bruno le maire qui était
plutôt guerrier hier dans ses paroles
avec voilà ce champ lexical un combat
est ce qu'avec ses déclarations on peut
comprendre on peut craindre par tant que
des répercussions
pour l'économie française mais aussi des
utilisateurs français
oui l'on peut toujours c'est bien le
problème c'est qu'avec justement les
joueurs du numérique ce qui s'est passé
c'est comme on a craint leur puissance
bas ils l'ont ils ont installé chaque
gouvernement a bien vu effectivement qui
perdaient un petit peu de pouvoir par
rapport à eux que ce soit encore une
fois sous l'angle effectivement
politique ou sous l'angle économique ce
qui est quand même ce qui nous touche
aujourd'hui suite à la la le reportage
sur la colline où vous avez bien donner
un peu lol la problématique aujourd'hui
économique d'un pays comme la france
or au moment où par exemple justement on
ferme les petits magasins etc en amazone
de l'autre côté là tout d'un coup il
faut reprendre main or on n'a pas de
capacité de reprendre main sur ces sur
ce système là donc c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement doit agir
il peut agir il faut voir que parent
précemment il ya eu quand même quelque
chose qui s'est passé il ya eu ce qu'on
a appelé l'invalidation du prix va si
schild
c'est un peu technique juridique mais c
est le fait tout simplement
qu'aujourd'hui on considère que les
données personnelles des utilisateurs
européens ne sont pas naïfs dans les
grandes cloud américains et que donc
d'une certaine manière on doit re
localiser les données à celles
opportunité pour l'europe de reprendre
un petit peu
j'en veux dire sa souveraineté numérique
c'est bien le sujet que derrière pense
qu'il faut pas craindre
justement ce qu'il ya derrière au
contraire on pourra inventer des
services des systèmes qui nous
ressemblent parce que c'est pas ça aussi
qui est l'objet ou celui de leurs afin
de fabriquer sa propre culture plutôt
pour les films d'importer juste des
blockbusters américains
on se souvient qu'en octobre les 137
pays membres de l' ocde ont échoué à
s'entendre pour imposer une fiscalité ce
qu'aujourd'hui
les gouvernements européens pourraient y
arriver s'explique d'ailleurs beaucoup
sur les plateaux en ce moment parce qu
il y sort sa loi dans moins d'un mois
donc le 4 novembre prochain et a priori
les européens sont pas loin d'un accord
maintenant ce pas parce qu'il ya un
accord au niveau européen qui sera
déployée parce qu'ils doivent être
déployés au niveau national il faut
jamais oublier que cette double
articulation
il faut pas oublier aussi qu'il ya
beaucoup de pays européens qui en
profite
l'irlande par exemple profite énormément
d'eux justement la manne des grands
joueurs du numérique qui sont installés
là-bas mais c'est pareil pour la
hollande quand la dpi qui fiscalement
jouent pas le jeu de l'europe
c'est là où la france mais aussi
l'allemagne aujourd'hui ont décidé un
petit peu que ça change
il faut pas oublier que quand on est à
plus de 130% aussi aujourd'hui déficit
du pib avec ce qui s'est passé sur avec
l'aco vide a effectivement l'état
cherche de l'argent donc il va les
chercher là où il y en a et aujourd'hui
il ya beaucoup d'argent dans des géants
du numérique dans les paradis fiscaux il
des milliards qui sont effectivement
stocker donc légitimement l'europe et
donc la france bien connu d'ailleurs
pour sa capacité à mettre en place des
nouveaux impôts
c'est nous qui avons inventé la tva fin
juillet ça au niveau mondial est en
train de montrer un peu la voix et je
pense qu'une bonne chose
il n'y a aucune raison qu'il n'y ait pas
de taxation de ces entreprises
contrairement à toutes les autres sur
lequel effectivement le départ a une
capacité d'aller prendre l'argent là où
il est dernière question à garnier on
est dans l'attenté de connaître le nom
de futur locataire de la maison blanche
dans le cas où dubai donne gagnerait
l'élection
qu'est-ce que comment les états unis
vont réagir on sait que donald trump
avait en contrepartie de la taxe gaffe a
décidé de surtaxer de 25 % les produits
français le vin notamment sur le pacs
faut pas être naïf
les américains mais en général et bien
avant train peu sont protectionnistes
depuis toujours on a toujours eu dès
lors qu'il ya eu des bras de fer
économique avec les américains des
rétorsions
c'est le cas pour l'europe mais c'est le
cas aussi justement pas pour la russie
ces cas pour la chine et les américains
sont coutumiers du fait
et ça n'a rien à voir avec la couleur
politique c'est vraiment dans leurs
gènes et c'est ce qui leur permet
d'ailleurs seront d'ailleurs ce que on
est de créer justement des conditions de
marché qui leur sont favorables et qui
assoient leur domination
ce qui s'est passé par un pack légendes
numérique donc moi je pense qu'on n'a
pas attendre grand chose de ce côté là
en revanche en revanche je craque pour
la la paix dans le monde et puis une
certaine stabilité peut-être on pourra
peut-être avoir des choses un peu plus
équilibré avec byron on aura juste un
petit peu moins de fun sur twitter mais
sur fun live quand même un peu dangereux
au niveau mondial
merci beaucoup à l'art garnier d'avoir
répondu à nos questions j'en ai fait je
rappelle que vous êtes président de
jamespot et porte-parole de france à
digital